[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei Bild wer
protestieren will der muss auffallen der
muss laut sein schrill und frech aber
sich seit Monaten immer wieder auf die
Straße kleben stundenlang blockieren
sabotieren damit Menschenleben riskieren
wie weit ist es da vom Aktivismus noch
zum Terrorismus was darf Protest darüber
diskutiere ich heute Abend mit diesen
Gästen nämlich mit Florian Zander
verurteilter klimaaktivist bei der
Gruppe xtinction Rebellion er hatte sie
ganz Verkehrsministerium gekettet
Bettina Rühl ist bei uns Journalistin
Autorin und
terrorismusexpertin Tochter der
rf-gründerin Ulrike meinhoff haha schuld
ist bei uns Aktionskünstler seine Kunst
provoziert und ist auch oft Protest
Helmut Thoma Medienmanager langjähriger
RTL Boss Mike Mohring CDU
Vorstandsmitglied ist bei uns und
zugeschaltet manche sagen Deutschlands
hat es da Innenminister bayerns
Innenminister Joachim Herrmann allen
einen schönen guten Abend in dieser
Runde ich habe sie gerade schon
vorgestellt
ja selbstgenannte Aktivist bei der
Gruppe extinction Rebellion wann kam bei
ihnen der Punkt wo sie gesagt haben das
normale reicht nicht mehr aus ab jetzt
wird sich festgekettet zumindest ans
Verkehrsministerium also ich sehe mich
erstmal als Wissenschaftler ich habe vor
ein paar Monaten meinen Doktor
abgeschlossen und habe viele Jahre lang
viel über die Klimakrise erfahren und
gemerkt dass die Politik da nicht
ausreichend darauf reagiert ja
Wissenschaftlerinnen waren seit
Jahrzehnten und aber wann war der Punkt
bei Ihnen wo Sie gesagt haben okay auch
Protest auf die Straße geht
demonstrieren reicht nicht mehr aus ab
jetzt klebe ich mich fest Kette ich mich
fest ja ich habe mit Protest schon vor
fünf Jahren angefangen und vor zwei
Jahren war es dann soweit da habe ich
mich vor dem Verkehrsministerium
angekettet weil ich keinen anderen
Ausweg mehr gesehen habe und den zivilen
oder Ungehorsam den zivilen Widerstand
habe ich dann als ja letzte Möglichkeit
wir sehen hier Bilder von ihren Aktionen
auch von dieser Aktion am
Verkehrsministerium sie sind dafür
erstmal verurteilt worden sie gehen noch
mal im Berufung aber es gab einen
Prozess sie dafür verurteilt worden zu
70 Tagessätzen 700 Euro insgesamt
Geldstrafe was hat Ihnen das sonst
gebracht außer einer Menge Ärger also
ich habe intensive Diskussion mit der
Richterin gehabt und die hat anerkannt
dass wir uns in einem planetaren
Notstand befinden nur das Mittel war
nicht richtig aber da werden wir jetzt
mit der nächst höheren Instanz darüber
streiten sie halten das Mittel nach wie
vor für richtig absolut haben sie
Sympathie Herr Schuld mit all den
Aktionen die sie schon gestartet haben
auch Sie haben Verkehr Alarm gelegt sie
haben Straßen vollgemüllt Innenstädte
vollgemüllt schon in den 60er 70er
Jahren haben sie Sympathie für ihn na
erstmal sehe ich dass der Hermann da so
rüber lächelt weil der ging damals noch
zur Schule wie ich das ganze gemacht
habe da war noch Franz Josef Strauß der
alte Waffenlobby ist der CSU für diese
Sachen zuständig und ich würde mich
jetzt freuen was der nachher zu ihm sagt
ja der kommt
aus Bayern geflüchtet vor dem
Franz-Josef Strauß damals ne
nicht getraut und deswegen hat er sich
nach Berlin getraut jetzt der ist ja
jetzt auf selber aber sie hätten sich
nicht getraut damals in München die
Aktion zu starten ich habe sie doch
gemacht
ein Enkelkind von mir das hat ganz klar
und das ist wunderbar nur wir haben
damals gekämpft dass solche Kinder jetzt
in die Welt gekommen sind aber wenn ich
den Spiegel Titel von heute sehe dann
seid Ihr ja langsam auch aufgewacht
können wir gerade mal zeigen das ist
nämlich der im Grunde der gleiche wie
1986 und hat den Kölner ordentlich unter
Wasser gesetzt das ist das Cover also
links 86 dann rechts für die Situation
das sind die Spieler vom Spiegel das ist
doch beim Spiegel ein Garten wie ein
gärtnerverein die reden doch sich selber
nach dem Mund das sieht man doch hier da
findet doch nichts Neues statt der
Spiegel hat früher gegen mich gehetzt
wie ich auf die Straße gehe und der
Spiegel ist jetzt langsam aufgewacht
weil da irgendwie eine alte Nummer
entdeckt aber Thomas sie haben schon
gerade dazwischen gerufen das Cover
zeigt doch eigentlich
heute Titel mehr aus praktischen Gründen
es ist es ist wie schrecklichen
schrecklich ist das in Wahrheit immer
wieder immer wenn man ein bisschen
länger da ist das sind sie auch dann
weiß man dass zum Beispiel schon einmal
der gesamte Wald vernichtet wurde es
gibt das Waldsterben vor was ich wie
viel Jahren da hat alle Tore gesagt in
2022 das Stern dem ich ansonsten sehr
schätze gibt es keinen Baum mehr also
die sind lauter fiktive Bäume die jetzt
hier rumlaufen also das ist alles absurd
was hier läuft er hat doch endlich mit
der Historie auf ich meine das ist doch
ihr glaubt immer dass das jetzt so viel
wisst ihr wisst gar nichts ich möchte
von dir hätten sie dort angekettet
gelassen was machen sie mit ihrem Leben
als angekette Dampf ist Verkehrsmittel
ganz gut andere Sachen zu tun in meinem
Leben die Hamburger hafenbühne die wird
mich nehmen aber mich wird auch die TU
Dave nehmen
ich mache das aber aus dem Grund weil
die Wissenschaft und die aller aller
meisten wissenschaftlichen sagen wir
befinden uns in einer Klimakrise und
wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln dann
Umwelt und Klimakrise bedeutet dass wir
eine erdäpfung haben wissen Sie wie viel
tote wir hatten dieses Jahr im Sommer in
Europa
er mehr als sie aber überhaupt nicht die
Wissenschaft weiß man dass man nichts
weiß im Wahrheit das ist ja das lustige
es es ist im Grund genommen wir müssen
dafür bescheidener werden ich meine wie
viel Krisen hat dieses dieser Welt schon
durchstanden ich meine wann immer
vorstelle was ist hier schon alles
gegeben hat hier irgendwo in der Gegend
wahrscheinlich in Berlin gab schon
einmal
Ozean es ist überhaupt was darf ich
alles
die Bilder von Herrn Zander gezeigt und
wie er sich da festgefettet hättet hat
würden sie er selbst sagt ja Aktivist
würden sie ihn noch als Aktivisten
bezeichnen oder möglicherweise schon als
Terroristen
Unsinn natürlich muss man mit der Welt
friedlich umgehen deshalb Warcraft Frage
aber sie dieses ganze Historie die sich
da entwickelt die tut dann hier bewegt
ich meine von zwei Prozent und wie viele
Leute wisst ihr das überhaupt was ist
Klima die kann ich mir klingt noch immer
im Ohr dieses vom vom Rudi Carrell das
muss auch hier ihr Lied sein wann wird
es endlich wieder Sommerreifen
kurzzeitig ins Lächerliche Thomas sagt
das ist ja alles ab dass sie der
veranstalten gibt heftigen Widerstand
von der Gruppe extinction Rebellion wir
müssen nur eine über einen sehr ernsten
Vorfall hier aus Berlin sprechen es hat
vergangene Woche ihren schweren Unfall
gegeben ein Betonmischer hat eine
Radfahrerin umgenietet überfahren und
man hat dann anschließend mit der
Rettungskräften dort im Stau gesteckt
auch weil die Straßen blockiert waren
von sogenannten Klima Klebern das heißt
haben diese Menschen mittlerweile auch
ein Menschenleben auf dem Gewissen ihrer
Meinung also ich denke mal das werden
die Gerichte entscheiden das weiß im
Moment keiner eine Notärztin hat ja
behauptet was ich ein bisschen
zweifelhaft fand das die einfach so groß
dann dargestellt wurde dass
klimaaktivisten keine Schuld haben das
wissen wir noch nicht in Kauf genommen
dass es Opfer gibt wird ja in jedem Fall
wenn man den Verkehr in der Form stört
also das ist schon im Sommer von gesagt
von von vielen Seiten es kann im Stau
können Schwangere sein es kann viele
Notfälle da sein also das wird in Kauf
genommen und das halte ich für absolut
super problematisch und deshalb
bin ich auch dagegen ich finde die
Anmaßung dass ein paar wenige Leute
sagen wir wissen jetzt alles und wir
wir stören jetzt einfach die
Gesellschaft und nehmen die Lebensgefahr
in Kaufes spielt gar keine Rolle ob
jetzt diese tote ob das eine Schuldfrage
ist es spielt eigentlich eine Rolle dass
es in Kauf genommen wird und deshalb bin
ich eigentlich gegen diese Methoden und
ich finde sie total anmaßend und es ist
so eine so eine Heiligkeit also dass wir
wissen es und wir bringen es alle
anderen in der Gesellschaft bei und ich
behaupte vor allem es nützt überhaupt
nichts was da geschieht also das für das
Klima ist es nicht in Ordnung für die
Wirtschaft bringt es nicht fürs Land
bringt es nicht was ich gut finde was
ich jetzt gehört habe wenn jemand
Fachmann ist was Klima angeht dann
möchte ich die Expertise die wollen wir
alle gerne hören das finde ich spannend
das kann ich auch anerkennen aber
einfach zu sagen wir sind jetzt
erleuchtet und diese Attitüde ist da und
wir setzen uns hin und stören und wir
nehmen auch Menschenleben in Kauf das
ist
kulturrevolutionär mehr noch als
terroristisch und kulturrevolutionär das
muss ich mal dazu sagen das ist ja auch
das Thema meines Buches ist
in von Warze Ton erfunden der die Jugend
in China was dann die 68er nachgemacht
haben aufgemogelt hat für seine Ziele
einfach auf die Straße zu gehen und
Chaos zu machen und zwar mit ganz
ähnlichen
Worthülsen die sie heute noch passieren
Antikapitalismus
Weltrettung wir stürmen einfach
Kultur also wir
stürmen die Paläste hat mal zu tun
gesagt und ich würde nee
Namen des des größten völkermörders
utong dessen Methoden würde ich nicht
übernehmen das haben die 68er schon
getan jetzt haben wir es mit den Enkeln
zu tun und ich bin absolut für Expertise
ich bin absolut dafür zu hören was die
klimakritiker sagen was auch die
Wissenschaft sagt und da ist die ganze
Gesellschaft bereit für also es gibt ja
schon von Ursula von der Lage der hat
den Notstand
schon ausgerufen vor zwei Jahren Herr
Habeck habe ich gestern gehört also
unsere ganze Regierung ist ja schon auf
der Seite es bringt also nichts mit
kulturrevolutionären Methoden
Menschenleben zu gefährden und der
ganzen Gesellschaft irgendeine Sache
aufzudrängen die die so nicht hören sind
bringt nichts sagt Bettina Röhl und das
riskiert sogar jetzt Menschenleben Herr
moring und trotzdem erleben wir das ja
seit Monaten mittlerweile seit Jahren
sogar so lange engagiert sich ja Herr
Zander schon so aktiv in dieser Bewegung
dort also jeden Tag passiert das auf den
Straßen obwohl Frau Röhl jetzt sagt das
riskiert mittlerweile Menschenleben
warum
es verändert sich was in Deutschland das
merkt man seit einigen Jahren
wir sind nicht mehr in der Lage
miteinander zu diskutieren keine heute
im anderen mehr zu die Gesellschaft
läuft auseinander und die Gewaltspirale
nimmt zu wir sehen das ja wir haben vor
ein paar Jahren im Strafgesetzbuch einen
neuen Tatbestand eingeführt Gefährdung
von berufshelfern weil wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen konnten vorher dass wir
Rettungssanitäter Feuerwehrleute im
Einsatz sind dass die angegriffen werden
und die zu schützen haben wir das
Strafgesetz an der Stelle erweitert und
jetzt diskutieren wir wieder über neue
Normen die man bitte machen müssen weil
wir sehen dass die Eskalation die Mittel
aggressiver werden das anketten
ist dahin genommen und wenn es eine
Strafe gibt folgt die auf dem Fuße das
ist so aber jetzt erleben wir ja das
möglicherweise gar nicht auf dem Fuß
hätte das sagen sie so das folgt dir gar
nicht auf dem Fuß dann können wir gerade
machen wann war ihr Prozess nach der
Tatort am Verkehrsminister zwei Jahre
später drei Jahre später
genau die Frage auf welcher Perspektive
Moment das sieht zunächst würde ich mal
sagen jeder Protest das kommt aus
unserer Freiheit in der Demokratie ist
zunächst legitim das gehört zu unseren
Freiheitsrecht natürlich besser kämpft
haben dass wir demonstrieren dürfen dass
unsere Meinung sagen dürfen dass wir uns
versammeln dürfen aber unsere
Freiheitsrechte sind dort begrenzt wo
wir andere Freiheitsrechte von anderen
wieder begrenzen und dass der Staat dann
da das zu ordnen unsere Regeln durch
Gesetze erleben gerade das genau diese
gesetzliche gebrochen werden durch genau
diese das ist Bewegung eine Frage
diskutieren wir gleich weiter Herrmann
gewaltfrei das Stichwort viel gerade von
Herrn Zander wir sind Gewalt ist das so
Ihrem Empfinden ihren Beobachtungen nach
nein das ist es eben leider nicht denn
es wird hier natürlich schon Gewalt
ausgeübt ist werden Menschen genötigt
sie können eben nicht die Straßen
benutzen diese benutzen wollen es hat
Hausfriedensbruch stattgefunden es wurde
in Häuser anderer Menschen eingedrungen
und auch auf der nachdrücklich bitten
das Haus nicht wieder verlassen wir
haben bei BMW festgestellt auch
Hausfriedensbruch die Firma BMW sagt an
den Fahrzeugen dort in der
Ausstellungshalle in der BMW Welt ist
das wird im Moment noch überprüft ein
Schaden zwischen 100.000 und einer
Millionen Euro entstanden wer sich so
aufführt wer derartig vorgeht der kann
doch nicht davon sprechen dass er
gewaltfrei unterwegs ist sondern da wird
in der Tat brutale Gewalt verübt die
überwiegend noch gegen Sachen aber wir
wissen leider aus der Erfahrung in der
Vergangenheit auch wer anfängt brutal
gegen Sachen Gewalt zu verüben das ist
ja auch so wenn einer da in die Museen
stürmt und
wertvolle Bilder beschädigt da ist die
Gefahr immer groß dass das irgendwann
auch in Gewalt gegen Menschen
unmittelbar umschlägt das Schuld das ist
Nötigung das ist ein Stück weit
Erpressung wenn man diejenigen die es
eilig haben zur Arbeit fahren wollen
morgens immer und immer wieder dazu
zwingt im Stau zu stehen sich dadurch
politische Dinge zu erpressen oder
wollen sie widersprechen natürlich ist
das Nötigung und man sollte diesen
Burschen einsperren das ist völlig in
Ordnung weil die Deutschen Gefängnisse
die sind ja geheizt im Winter in den
deutschen Gefängnissen geht es einem
recht gut man kann auch sein Doktortitel
noch mal
überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht dies
wird viel zu hoch gehängt von diesem
Sheriff aus Bayern das ist eine ganz
harmlose Geschichte was hier stattfindet
und auch von ihnen das ist auch für Sie
da dass sie diesen einen Unfall daher
zaubern nein das ist eine Zahl
überhaupt nicht dass Maßstab wird
vollkommen verrückt denken Sie mal daran
was zur selben Minute im Mittelmeer an
toten dort entstehen und dass diese
braven Kinder endlich aufgewacht sind
doch nicht der Wohlstandsgesellschaft
die Kinder all dieser Spieße die über
viele Jahrzehnte zugeguckt haben wie
sich die Welt veränderte wir sind
Spieler
die Sendung an die er früher gemacht hat
das natürlich ein spießer-sendung
Generation selbst geschaffen
einmal ganz kurz direkt angesprochen
mach doch einmal man ist ja immer das
begriffliche die einen agieren mit
Begriffen wie Klima ja was überhaupt
nicht was Klima ist das kann die
nächsten 50 Jahre jetzt 30 Jahre jetzt
festgelegt warum das 100 das sind in der
in der Erdgeschichte
Sekundenbruchteile und ich meine dieses
ewig des apothekische zu erklären was
was ich verändert ihr wisst gar nichts
wie es zum Beispiel dass Sie dass die
dass die Umdrehungsgeschwindigkeit der
Erde leicht zunimmt was das auslöst wir
wissen es nicht wir sitzen in einem
ungeheueren Universum und tun so als
wenn man irgendwas Regeln können wir
auch diese co2-geschichte na gut daneben
ist Methan was in dem Norden
weil nicht nur Spießer sondern sie haben
alle die Generation die Eltern
Generation viel zu lange zugeguckt sie
haben sie ausprobieren
das war der Vorwurf von der
problematisch
die 60er Jahre wo wir alle schon wussten
also ich habe in seiner Zeit im alten
simpel hier mein Freund Hermann ne da
waren Sina in der Schule
nein das ist ja nicht
persönlich
Fridericianum Musik Museum habe ich
schon Gymnasium nein damals habe ich zu
Willy Brandt am Tisch im alten simpel
gesagt 1969 eines Tages wird die Umwelt
die Welt verändern und das Thema wird
uns alle bestimmen da rief mein Freund
heute ebke über den Tisch halt du deine
Mund geh lieber zu CSU wir wollen
Kanzler und so wurden sie Kanzler aber
da kommt jetzt etwas mein Freund zum zum
sagen wenn man die Wahrheit sagt wird
man nicht Kanzler das wissen wir von den
derzeitig amtierenden
in diesem Land Zander einmal Ring nach
Luft und will einmal aufhören Hermann
Antworten der ihm massiv Erpressung
Nötigung vorgeworfen hat ja ich will nur
einmal darauf eingehen wollen als
wissenschaftlich gerne wollen weil ich
bin ja auch als Wissenschaftler und zwar
die Wissenschaft waren seit Jahrzehnten
und wenn die Politik nicht in der Lage
ist darauf einzugehen und richtige
Mittel zu ergreifen dann sage ich als
Wissenschaftler das ist richtig was die
Menschen dort machen und nicht nur ich
als Wissenschaftler andere
Wissenschaftler auch in Süddeutschland
dann sagen sie wenn das nicht richtig
läuft da oben dann ist Demokratie für
mich nichts Demokratie ist das
Wichtigste was wir haben nur die wird
gerade unter wandert durch Lobbyismus in
der Politik wie kann es zum Beispiel
sein das wie kann es zum Beispiel sein
dass die Deutsche Bank in dem letzten
Jahr über 1,1 Milliarden Euro Gewinn
gemacht hat aber Menschen gerade nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Stromrechnung
bezahlen
neben mir ist jetzt wichtig die die über
das System zu sprechen weil ich habe sie
gefragt ob sie an die Demokratie glauben
und sie haben gesagt eigentlich ist das
das Beste was wir haben aber es
funktioniert nicht das heißt wollen Sie
ein anderes System nein die Demokratie
ist das was wir brauchen wir brauchen
mehr Demokratie und auch die Demokratie
innerhalb der Demokratie habe ich
persönlich alle möglichen Mittel der
Demonstration ausgeschöpft ich habe auch
in der Wissenschaft viele Mittel
ausgeschöpft glauben Sie mir wenn man
mir nicht zuhört und meinen ganzen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann haben wir
ein Problem denn wenn die Welt zwei oder
drei Grad wärmer wird was passiert denn
dann wenn dann ist es nicht so dass ein
paar Bäume sterben dann werden es massiv
leiten
und zu der Radikalität möchte kurz sagen
das was jetzt als radikal geframt wird
das sind
Straftaten allerdings die Nötigung die
dann zutrifft der Umweg der Stau ist
finden so viel Staus in Deutschland
jedes Jahr statt sie konnten mehr ihre
einzelne tat das stimmt doch gar nicht
die Radikalität die uns in Zukunft
erwartet ist viel größer auch das
rechtfertige das nicht aber das ist
genau ihr Staatsverständnis was ist
schwierig ist sie sagen sie haben eine
legitimes Ziel und dieses legitime Ziel
rechtfertigt auch Gewalttaten und
Straftaten genau das stimmt eben nicht
weil keine auch kein gutes Ziel
rechtfertigt dem Gesetzesbruch und das
genau der Unterschied den haben wir oft
bei links und rechts Debatten es ist
auch so das linke sagen ihre ihre Taten
sind gerechtfertigt weil sie von gutes
Ziel eintreten und Nazis vom Grunde her
sowieso nicht da kann man lange darüber
streiten was da richtig ist aber auch
bei ihnen habe ich es mehrmals in
Diskussion gehört dass sie sagen wir
haben ein wichtiges Ziel das Klima die
Klimakatastrophe droht und deshalb ist
meine Tat gerechtfertigt damit stellen
sie ja den Staat an sich in Frage damit
stellen sie die Demokratie in Frage und
damit tragen sie genau dazu bei was ich
vorhin beschrieben habe dass die Leute
unsere Demokratie nicht mehr zutrauen im
Osten mittlerweile nur noch 38 Prozent
das kommt auch durch solche Taten weil
sie den Start in Frage stellen die
genommenen Frage stellen und sagen sie
wissen es besser wie es geht und damit
bringen sie unsere Zusammenhalt
durcheinander sie haben gerade gehört
was Herr Dr Zander auf sie gerade
geantwortet hatte Hermann das heißt mit
dem müssen sie sich ja sozusagen wenn es
auch nicht ganz hier Bundesland ist
weiter rumschlagen wie gehen Sie mit dem
um der ganz offen sagt ich glaube nicht
an das was ihr beschließt glaubt nicht
an das was ihr an Politik macht ich
werde andere Wege gehen
ich bin was die Sache des Klimaschutzes
zusammen betrifft anderer Meinung als
Herr Thoma das ist völlig klar aber das
ist jetzt hier heute denke ich nicht
meine Hauptjob zu sagen was müssen wir
alles für den Klimaschutz tun wollen
da geht es darum dass wir geordnete
Spielregeln in unserem Land haben müssen
weil es viele Leute gibt da schließe ich
gerne das was Mike Mohring gerade gesagt
hat die sagen ich habe meine Überzeugung
und für die Kämpfe ich dafür leben wir
in der Demokratie dafür haben wir
Meinungsfreiheit dafür haben wir
Versammlungsfreiheit aber würde jeder
dafür seine Überzeugungen auf die Straße
gehen und versuchen andere Menschen
davon zu erzeugen das Problem bei Herr
Zander Entschuldigung
geil soll ich nach Süddeutschland kommen
nicht darum dass ich die Leute
einsperren will sondern es geht darum es
geht darum dass der Herr Zander es
bisher nicht geschafft hat eine Mehrheit
der Menschen in Deutschland von seinen
Überzeugungen seinerseits
in Deutschland bringt nicht so wer
Zander und das Problem das Problem dass
der Zander jetzt sagt weil er es nicht
geschafft hat mit seiner Argumentation
und seinen Demonstrationen die Menschen
zu überzeugen deswegen meinte ich jetzt
Gewalt gerechtfertigt und wenn wir das
Anfangen in unserem Staat dass jeder der
meint dass er mit demokratischen Mitteln
keine Mehrheit erreichen kann deswegen
Gewalt anwenden kann dann ist dieser
Staat kaputt dann ist diese und das ist
genau das Problem und allein die
polternden Worte jetzt aus München oder
aus Erlangen werdens werden Herrn Zander
vermutlich Herrn Dr Zander nicht nicht
überstimmen das heißt sie haben ja jetzt
schon zu einem anderen Mittel gegriffen
in Bayern und haben heute weggesperrt
haben die in der restzellen gesetzt im
Moment in München würden sie das mit
Herrn Zander also auch machen
wenn zum Beispiel wie jemand der wenn
jemand wie in der BMW Welt das Beispiel
habe ich vorhin angesprochen
Hausfriedensbruch begeht der grobe
Sachbeschädigung beginnt und ankündigt
dass er das bei nächster Gelegenheit
sobald er wieder nach der entsprechenden
Personalienfeststellung von der Polizei
freigelassen wird ist wieder tut ja das
ist in der Tat gerechtfertigt dass ein
Richter sich mit der Frage beschäftigt
entsprechend zu jemanden auch richtig
sparsam zu nehmen und das haben Richter
angeordnet und das ist aus meiner Sicht
auch die richtige Reaktion ich muss auf
der anderen Seite aber bitte auch
feststellen es ist doch keine
Massenbewegung wenn sie mal sehen wie
viel Leute
aufhören die überwältigende Mehrheit die
überwältigende Mehrheit der Menschen in
Deutschland denkt eben nicht so wie er
Zander und hält auch diese Aktionen
wir stehen jetzt deswegen jetzt nicht
vor dem Kollaps diese Stapel aber wir
sagen ganz klar dass wir solche
jeden Morgen in den großen Städten in
Deutschland wie viele sind es denn
aktuell haben sie Erkenntnisse werden
das gerade immer mehr
wir haben da insgesamt keine Gesamtzahl
bislang wir beobachten das was ich jetzt
der schwerpunktmäßig gerade den letzten
14 Tagen in München getan hat dabei
waren aber sehr viele Ausländer da waren
Italiener Franzosen Spanier dabei also
es ist ja die Reisen quer durch Europa
und machen da jeweils ihre
Schwerpunktaktionen
Nebel wenn wir das hören wir wissen
gerade nicht werden das immer mehr nach
der Aktion und in Berlin wo ist der
heftige Diskussion noch zurecht gehabt
nach dem Unfall hätte man ja gedacht
okay jetzt lass mal Ruhe setze ich dann
niemand mehr
die Straße nicht so tun als wenn es
jetzt nur so ein paar Wissenschaftler
oder Studenten sind die das mal so
nebenbei machen sondern es ist ja
relativ organisiert hat er jetzt ein
paar Artikel gegeben dass es auch
ziemlich große Geldgeber gibt und das
ist auch ziemlich durchorganisiert ist
es muss jetzt nicht er wird ja auch
verschiedene Organisationen ich weiß
nicht letzte Generation Ende Gelände
existieren schon Rebellen es gibt also
Millionär
ist nicht so klein und ich denke mal bis
jetzt ist es nicht terroristisch oder
keine Gewalt und so weiter aber das kann
tatsächlich jederzeit kippen denn wenn
man sich einmal den Anspruch sagt wir
müssen jetzt gehört werden also um
diesen Kipppunkt
dann dann dann kann es sehr leicht sein
dass man sagt es sind auch krassere
Aktionen
erlaubt das war damals muss ich aber von
der Historie sagen bei der 68er
Rebellion genauso das war hieß waren
genauso damals wie gesagt haben Gewalt
nur gegen Sachen es hat sich dann
gesteigert dann hattest durch durch
sozusagen Zufall die ersten Toten
gegeben in München bei einer
Demonstration die auch aus dem eigenen
Lager
kam was wurde dann auch gelogen
und fast niemand hat sich so intensiv
mit diesem Thema beschäftigt wie sie
mit ihrer Arbeit journalistisch als
Autorin aber vor allen Dingen mit ihrer
Biografie natürlich auch als Tochter von
Ulrike meinhoff das heißt sie haben
gerade über diesen Kipppunkt
gesprochenpunkt
Terrorismus wird also ich würde das
jetzt vor allen Dingen als jemand sagen
der das recherchiert hat und auch
analysiert hat es hat diesen Kipppunkt
gegeben weil dann innerhalb dieser
Strukturen natürlich auch dann die
radikalerin oft singen es sind natürlich
viele Leute die mit einem guten Willen
angefangen haben wir 68 auch aber es
gibt dann es innerhalb der Strukturen
gewinnen dann oft nicht die vernünftigen
sondern immer die die noch die größere
Aktion machen wie viel besseren Werbung
machen man kämpft für eine gute Sache
das verbindet reise ich würde sagen
jeder tipppunkt hat noch nicht
stattgefunden und hoffentlich
hoffentlich findet er nicht statt aber
es ist es gibt sozusagen die Möglichkeit
wenn es Protagonisten in dieser Bewegung
sich nach oben ploppen was wir nicht
hoffen also was
findest du damals ist das auch diese
Sachen diese ganzen Rebellionen ja nicht
von unten alleine kommt sondern
angefangen an verwurzelt mit ganz
starken establishment-größen bei den
Grünen bei der SPD bei den Linken und
auch bei großen Geldgebern
ja das war bei 68 übrigens auch so auch
die sind damals sehr sehr früh
finanziert worden entscheidend von
großfinanzieren also davon ganz
Klarmobil das Geld Einzelspender das
sind alle die Einzelspender deswegen
sind die Privatpersonen ja
Privatpersonen sind auch ja das ist so
das sind so 100 € von meine Eltern
finanzieren mich auch so 2019 haben wir
amerikan gemacht jetzt machen wir
Straßenblockaden das ist keine
Erscheinungstermine
geht
einen Kipppunkt wo erklären Sie ein
Wissenschaft Punkt was ihre Biografie
angeht wo sie jetzt sagen Gewaltfreiheit
ist für mich wird aber es könnte andere
geben selber erfahren also wo ist bei
ihnen der Punkt wo sie sagen bis dahin
und auf keinen Fall weiter
ja bei allen Bewegungen die sie jetzt
genannt haben und vor allem ist die
Gewaltfreiheit der zivile Ungehorsam der
ja friedliche Ziele Ungehorsam dass Omas
der Limit da gibt es nichts es wird
nicht darüber hinausgehen jetzt wieder
Ungehorsam ist eine Form die wir
anwenden weil wir uns nicht weiter zu
helfen müssen ich würde gerne andere
Sachen machen aber mir bleibt keine
andere Wahl als Wissenschaftler mir
gehört zu schaffen
und ich muss jetzt wirklich eine Lanze
für Herrn Hermann brechen er hat nämlich
alles schon richtig gesagt er hat gesagt
ihr hängt das viel zu hoch mein Freund
Thomas hat es auch richtig gesagt was
sind denn das für Kinder die da auf der
Straße sind das ist die vierte
Generation der letzte Teebeutel Aufguss
von uns aus den 60er Jahren dass du
Augenblick dass du natürlich eine
gezeichnete bist das wissen wir jetzt
das ist leise ich dass du das
Aufarbeiten kannst
nein nein nein
ich habe darüber gesprochen deine
persönliche Biograf nein das hat er auch
gerade schon eben vorgetragen
gemacht Biografie finde ich bist du
derjenige der den ganzen Tisch hier
springt also das ist deine du bist das
ganze Ding mit 68
dass ihr das hoch hängt und dadurch so
wie du das auch befürchtest
diese ich sage trieben werden weil
Politiker also
die Politiker haben noch keine Antwort
das ist das Problem seine Leute
blockieren und sabotieren seit Jahren
Hermann inklusive der Händler Schuld die
über ihn berichten
was soll denn eigentlich passieren ich
kann nur noch einmal sagen wir haben
schon einmal die den Wald sterben gehabt
der Band 1200
Wissenschaftler die haben geschworen es
gibt nur wir haben bei einem noch aber
ich nehme an ist in der Familie
geblieben
ich musste wirklich nicht das Wort für
die klimaaktiv machen aber ehrlich mal
jetzt geht's wissen Sie wenn Sie im
Protest kommt hat er ja auch eine
Wirkung in der Gesellschaft dass die
Leute nachdenken ihre Verhalten musste
überprüfen die Industrie sich verändert
die Forschung ist stärker wird und das
passiert ist auch wieder die sind so
ungeduldig die glaube ich übertreiben es
auch da bin ich bei Ihnen wenn Sie sagen
dass ich das mal zu sagen die radikale
Position am Ende sieht und sagte sie
geht das nicht auf aber jeder Protest
hat am Ende auch was fruchtbringendes
weil in der Gesellschaft neu nachgedacht
haben
ich muss nur noch
Punkte
diese Leute kommen gleich zurück zu
Ihnen Herr morgen weil diese Leute ja
sagen sie glauben auch nicht an die
Veränderungsbereitschaft des Systems sie
haben sich das jetzt ja Jahre
angeguckt und sie meinen auf der
besseren auf der richtigen Seite aber
das ist ich würde sagen gucken wir uns
noch mal den
atomprotest an der hat dazu geführt der
flächendeck die atomprotest in den 80er
Jahren also ich war auch hatte auch so
ein Schild der tonkraft nein danke ohne
eine Ahnung zu haben
weil natürlich war ich gegen den Atom
Tod also wer es nicht gegen den Atom Tod
aber diese Bewegung hat dazu geführt
dass Angela Merkel die Atomkraftwerke
2011 abgeschaltet hat das heißt ich sag
jetzt mal so verkürzt
aber noch nicht deswegen nicht wegen dem
Protest der 80er Jahren
Baden-Württemberg in der Kreidezeit
Protest weil er man massenhaft geführt
ist ist richtig ich halte es für falsch
dass wir Deutschland auch sehr
Atomenergie ausgestiegen sind wir wären
heute längst bei besseren
Atomkraftwerken die jetzt in China zum
Beispiel gebaut werden kleine viel
saubere das ist alles abgeschaltet
worden in Deutschland würde es viel
besser gehen und es wäre auch von der
CO2 Seite her viel besser hätten sie
auch Atome ich will nur sagen es ist
nicht immer fruchtbar wenn man auf den
Massenprotest hört der aber
wissenschaftlich sehr oft unfundiert
kommt
so sie hören auf die Wissenschaft es
passieren Veränderungen das sehe ich
ganz anders das sehe ich ganz anders
weil wo sind die Veränderungen haben sie
den Herrn Antonio guterich gehört den
Rang Generalsekretär aktuell sagt ich
Klima kommt eigentlich wir die radikalen
sind sondern
viele Energien
aufgehört habe jetzt kommt der Punkt
dass wir ganz entscheidende ich habe ja
gesagt so eine gesellschaftliche Debatte
die bringt auch Bewegung in die
Forschung in die polit Entscheidung das
sehen wir gerade in Deutschland sie
fokussieren sich mit dem Protest auch
sehr auf Deutschland das Entscheidende
ist und das könnte eben auch zur Wahl
dazu selbst wieder in Deutschland alles
einhalten würden was sie Forderungen
nicht lassen nämlich der letzte zu Ende
sagen selbst wenn wir alles umsetzen
würden was Sie wollen dann reicht das
nicht weil das Weltklima insgesamt Sicht
auch durch Entscheidungen anderen
Ländern beeinflusst und jetzt kommt es
entscheidende dazu was ich vorhin gesagt
mit unserem Wert unser Demokratie hier
in diesem Land können sie demonstrieren
sie können sich anketten sie können auch
ein paar Tage sitzen bleiben dann werden
sie irgendwann bestraft dann können Sie
wieder hier sitzen können sie ja weiter
formulieren in Diktaturen in
unfreiheitlichen Gesellschaften können
sie das nicht machen und manchmal wäre
es auch mutig nicht nur hier in
Deutschland weil es hier und bestraft
bleibt ihrem Protest zu äußern sondern
die internationalen Kräfte von ihnen zu
unterstützen die in Ländern aktiv sind
wo es viel schwieriger ist wo sie mit
Leib und Leben solche Rechte eingreifen
müssen würden sie sich also wünschen
nicht in der Demokratie zu leben sondern
in einer Art klimadiktatur wo wir all
das was bei Ihnen auf dem
wissenschaftlichen Zettel in der Arbeit
steht einmal durchparken hier
einer Demokratie leben und ich nutze
auch und ja finde es gut dass
ich finde es nicht in Ordnung dass so
mit der Wissenschaft umgegangen wird
gesagt wird ja ja ihr sagt schon das
richtige aber wir hier Thomas das war
nur Thomas
zu tun
das Problem und Deutschland ist weit weg
davon seine eigene Klimaziele
einzureichen gerade nachdenken was für
Ausreden empfindet das ist nicht
schlecht
versuche ich in dieser Sendung
herauszufinden also eine besser auf die
Masse der Wissenschaften
Sie sich also Wünschen in dieser
Ökodiktatur zu leben und all das einmal
durchzupacken ich bin sehr froh dass wir
in der Demokratie leben
und deswegen müssen
in diesem Land in Ordnung solange wir
nicht die Eigentumsrechte oder
Arbeitnehmer
Punkt dort wo sie andere
Sachbeschädigung machen greifen sie in
andere Rechte ein da endet ihr
wahrscheinlich schließen Sie das gerade
angetextet hat es geht
durch Reiches Rechnung für alle
Entwicklung ihrer Bewegung zu einer ja
Öko RAF aus ja eindeutig wir sind
gewaltfrei wir bleiben gewaltfrei das
Diskutieren weiter in dieser Sendung
waren wir ganz kurz zu Hause zurück bis
gleich
zurück in diese Runde hat es nicht
ausgehalten
sind wieder mittendrin hier bei Bild bei
den richtigen Fragen wir diskutieren
darüber was darf Protest und das tun wir
unter anderem mit einem der klimakleber
von extinction Rebellion und das tun wir
auch mit haa schuldaktionskünstler der
immer wieder ja provokante Aktionen
gestartet hat und selber dafür auch
schon
wird natürlich dafür bestraft in dem
Land von Hermann und das war auch ganz
in Ordnung was genau ich finde das ganz
gut wenn man bestraft wird ich rate dir
das auch diese Zeit mal abzusitzen nicht
irgendwo in ein Arbeitslager zu gehen
wie das neulich jemanden
das ist ein schlechtes Beispiel macht
sowas bloß nicht auch noch ne darf ich
ein Flugzeugabstürzen lassen in New York
das ist eine andere Liga macht oder
so ja ja das Städte zugemüllt das war
tatsächlich war das war bei Hermann
damals war doch der Strauß dran ne und
Hermann hat es ja nicht mehr zu Strauß
geschafft aber es ist so nieder Sheriff
und hier sind sie im Vorschlaghammer
unterwegs gewesen
abends in einer Fernsehsendung da gucken
noch 18 Millionen Zuschauer zu die
Aktion genommen man hat auf den
Schreibtisch gehauen und hat gesagt
jetzt habe ich auch mal kurz gemacht der
würde hinterher intend also es geht
immer so weiter muss sie dafür für diese
oder ähnliche Aktion einsetzen
dass sie über kunstrede aber wir haben
die Zeit bewegt wir haben über Umwelt
gesprochen da habt ihr noch gar nicht
den Mund aufgemacht diese Kinder was
völlig in Ordnung ist du bist ja du bist
ja ein Kind an dann wieder anderen Zeit
aber wir haben in einer Zeit das Wort
Umwelt in unserem Mund genommen da hat
das kaum einer gebraucht wir Künstler
waren in den 60er Jahren lange vor dem
Clubhaus wirklich Alter Kaffee
Thüringen ja ist klar aber
kulturell in der Mond gewesen
ja die Aktionskunst ist in der DDR
verboten gewesen weil weil die weil die
DDR eine Kunst die den Mund aufmacht ist
in solchen Ländern nicht gewollt das
haben sie vorhin auch ganz kulturelle
sagen
uns unserer Zeit wir haben jetzt das
bewegt jetzt ist
wir müssen noch ausreden lassen können
ich sage immer zwei Dinge was mir jetzt
aufgefallen ist sie sagen das ist die
vierte Generation
Kinderautos damit stellen die ganze
Generation in Frage jede Generation
Frage
zweiter Punkt
wir hätten kulturelle in der Mond ich
komme aus dem kulturreichsten Bundesland
in der ganzen Bundesrepublik ja
Thüringen ist dort sind ganz viele große
Künstler groß geworden gerade vom Schnee
vom vorgestern das war ja noch länger ja
leider
in der Zeit der DDR da war diese Kunst
die ich gemacht habe verboten weil sie
nicht aufgemacht hast ich habe in diesem
Land gelebt eine Diktatur
schön auf dicke Hose machen und hier
Geschichten erzählen ich habe ein Land
gelebt wo das nicht möglich war die
Meinung zu sagen auf die Straße zu gehen
überall hin zu fahren
jetzt machen sie halt nee das war ich
nicht vor da war und deswegen habe
wenn ihr das Hören ändern
muss man so laut sein mittlerweile muss
man solche Aktionen auf die Straße
kleben festketten machen um überhaupt
wahrgenommen zu werden ihr Ofen aber
ansonsten ist es ja ein unsinniges ganze
aber bitte schön wenn es soweit dann
macht es heute ich meine das ist ja für
die kennt eben bitte das beste hat mir
gefallen irgendwo sich festbinden und
dann bleiben dort etwas also irgendwo
gelesen der Ötzi war vielleicht
allerdings vergessen haben
es hört sich irgendwo festgeklebt und
kann nicht mehr viel auszufinden aber
ist ja wirklich absurd was sich abspielt
immer es lässt sich diese
Wissenschaftler meine was heißt hier
Wissenschaft sie haben überhaupt keine
Ahnung gehört ja jetzt sind wir bei
diesen Aktionen und reden darüber muss
man das machen um aufzufassen alle
berichten in Deutschland ja aber schaut
euch doch einmal an wie die Franzosen
mit dem umgehen die gehen ein bisschen
brutaler und wir nehmen ganz einfach
das ist eine Gegenwehr ich meine das ist
das ist sicherlich ein riesen Problem
wie irgendeiner Form zu agieren was kann
ich wenn man jetzt vor der Situation
steht da steht ein Rettungswagen und
dahinter ist ist ein verunfalter und
dazwischen sind Leute die sich
festgeklebt haben sowas macht jetzt also
jetzt machen was konkret sie stehen da
im Stau stehen erste Reihe vorhin hat
sie sich Herr Dr Zander auf die Straße
gesetzt hat sich schon festgeklebt sie
warten jetzt erstmal schöne Stunde
Thomas im Berufsverkehr in Berlin da bin
ich sehr dafür und das sehr brutal zu
regeln not die Hände wegzureißen einmal
zu dem hin muss
runter wir müssen dorthin ja ist doch
das geht ums Leben
auf ihre Kappe jetzt sagt Ihnen Herr
Thoma ja der sonst weitestgehend einer
Meinung ist mit Ihnen hier in dieser
Runde heute abend sie sind viel zu weich
sie klopfen da große Sprüche in München
selbst im von Bayerns oder von
Deutschlands härtest im Innenminister
sagte das ist viel zu weit sie müssen es
halt erst sie müssen einfach runter
holen davon der Straße
haben wir extra inzwischen jetzt überall
Lösungsmittel um die Leute die sich
besser
manche lassen sich dann wieder neues
Klebemittel einfangen
in dem Stau steht und was da nämlich
passiert sieht anders aus als das was
die schildern das überall das
Lösungsmittel hergeholt wird und so da
guckt man zu wie sich festgeklebt wird
und dann kommen Rettungssanitäter dazu
weil es könnte ja bald ablösen nichts
passieren wird und es ist doch eine
Verhöhnung des Rechtsstaates da passiert
die Polizisten stehen stundenlang
daneben
nein das ist ja eben nicht der Fall wenn
wir rechtzeitig darauf aufmerksam werden
dann verhindern wir dass jemand sich da
festklebt und wir ständig das gehört
natürlich hier zu den besonderen
Herausforderungen dass die ja irgendwo
hingehen jedenfalls in Bayern haben wir
eine klare Linie wenn ihr irgendwo
verhindern
unsere Demokratie ja das darf ich Ihnen
vielleicht auch mal einmal Ausreden
jawohl
jawohl Innenminister ja und dann wieder
ich ja denn das entscheidende vorhin was
Herr Zander gesagt hat das ist diese
wissenschaftliche Arroganz die bei ihm
durchdringt ich habe großen Respekt vor
Wissenschaftlern aber demokratie heißt
das in unserem Staat jede Frau und jeder
Mann das gleiche Recht hat und jeder hat
bei der Abstimmung eine Stimme was sich
was so wie Herr Zander sich angehört hat
mündet daraus eine Anspruch dass er
einen größeren Anspruch hätte gehört zu
werden mit seinen Argumenten bei der
Wissenschaftler ist ja er kann mit
seinen Argumenten entsprechend
rüberkommen aber am Schluss gibt es eine
Abstimmung egal ob der Bundestag gewählt
wird oder eine Volksabstimmung in bei
einem Bürgerentscheid in München
stattfindet und da hat jede Frau und
jedermann das gleiche Recht er kann
nicht mit einer Arroganz auftreten dass
er das besser weiß als der erfahren oder
der Hausmeister vom Internist und das
müssen sie ja Zander jetzt mal
akzeptieren sie dreht mit einer Arroganz
auf weil sie Wissenschaftler sind hätten
sie einen Anspruche darauf dass alle auf
das zu hören haben was sie meinen und
das ist nicht aus
damit leben sie nämlich genau die
Grundsätze unserer Demokratie aus und
das ist nicht akzeptabel ich bin als
Innenminister dafür verantwortlich dass
weiterhin in diesem Land gilt gleiches
Recht für alle Grundlage unseres
corona-pandemie da wurde sehr gut auf
die Wissenschaft gehört wir tragen
Masken wir haben uns impfen lassen die
corona-pandemie ist eine Folge der
Umweltkrise warum wird nicht jetzt auf
die Wissenschaft gehört und etwas gegen
die Umwelt und auch gegen die Klimakrise
getan es geht glaube ich gerade sehr
durcheinander weil in der in dieser
corona-pandemie
wieder zurücknehmen
nie geschlossen werden müssen also
glaube beim BVG tragen wir auch die
Masken ich gehöre ja zu den Leuten diese
ganzen Corona Sachen alle befolgt haben
und so weiter ich würde sagen ich bin
auch keine klimaexpertin aber was ich
natürlich 2018 hat doch 19 angefangen
habe zu lesen ist dass es nicht so ist
wie ein Herr Riese und andere gesagt
haben dass alle Wissenschaftler sich
einig sind es gibt eine ganze Menge
Wissenschaftler die nicht der Meinung
sind dass wir in drei Jahren
den Kipppunkt haben es gibt ganz andere
die auch seriös wirken sagen es sind 80
Jahren noch irgendwie Zeit haben
da ich kann mich da nicht einmischen
weil ich keine wissen das werde ich auch
nicht mehr in meinem Leben aber es geht
ja darum wie kommt man jetzt effizient
dazu dass wir ein Klimaschutz in diesem
Land
und jetzt behaupte ich die ganzen
Aktionen die sie extrem Rebellen gemacht
hat und diese ganzen anderen
Gruppierungen haben bis jetzt 0,0 für
den Klimaschutz erreicht
genau
jetzt passiert genau das nämlich beim
Klima auch der klima-lockdown ja aber
entschuldigung es ist ja nicht
feststehend das ist doch immer wieder
was wie wird argumentiert
Wissenschaftler 1200 wissen das ist doch
gerade kein demokratischer Vorgang waren
1200 und es gibt dann vielleicht 800 die
dagegen sind also dann haben die haben
die Recht es ist nur Demokratie so aber
berichte stimmt nicht das sind weltweite
Wissenschaftler
aber sie hat gerade gesagt Sie haben
gerade Corona als Beispiel angeführt das
war der Testlauf ja wie man wie man
sozusagen testen kann wie man eine
Gesellschaft lahmlegen kann
der Klimakrise das habe ich gesagt der
Krone ist eine Folge der Umweltkrise
weil wir die Natur eingeschränkt haben
die Menschen leben mehr aber wir
Wünschen zusammen es gibt weniger
es könnte doch gar nicht belegen heute
abend
also ist das ich wünsche mir
BürgerInnenversammlung bürgerräte wo wir
als Beteiligten machen
wir wir verlangen das von der Politik
das
bürgerinnenräte eingeführt werden und
wir dann gemeinsam entscheiden von einem
Durchschnitt der Gesellschaft was für
klima-maßnahmen wir wollen wir brauchen
als Bevölkerung weil ich glaube nämlich
dass die Bevölkerung schlauer ist
teilweise als die Politik sie wollen
doch noch andere Systeme es tut mir leid
nein nein innerhalb der Demokratie mit
dieser müssen wir Bürgerinnen
sie wollen sich von unserem Grundgesetz
verabschieden
ausprobiert in Deutschland ja aber sie
wollen politische Entscheidung Ersetzen
von parlamentsentscheidungen sind
BürgerInnen und das ist ein anderes
System wir leben in der
parlamentarischen Demokratie wir geben
macht auf Zeit wir können die Leute
wieder abwehren wenn Sie falsche
Entscheidungen treffen wir können Sie
unterstützen wenn sie gute Entscheidung
getroffen haben wenn sie Vertrauen
genießen das Zeichen unserer Demokratie
aus das was sie machen wollen die
legitimierte Bürger Rede die quasi per
Zufallsprinzip sie zusammensetzen
Parlamentsentscheidung ersetzen ist
nicht dieselbe Demokratie in der wir
jetzt gerade leben können Sie mir
erklären wo die Politik richtige
Entscheidungen trifft wenn ein Konzern
wie
www.3 Monate drei acht Milliarden Euro
Gewinn gemacht haben können Sie das den
Leuten hier erklären
Milliarden Gewinn gemacht mit einem
netten wir wissen nicht wie wir
problemsmittel einkaufen sollen wir
wissen nicht wie wir unsere Gasrechnung
zahlen sollten darüber zu diskutieren
das wäre mal aber ja
mit den hohen Gasrechnungen machen in
der Tat und aber woran liegen den Punkt
den den Herr Dr Zander aufmacht ist das
Misstrauen in die Politik das erleben
wir ja nicht nur von den Klima Klebern
das erleben wir in weiten Teilen der
Bevölkerung mittlerweile das heißt das
scheint ja ein Punkt zu sein das
Misstrauen in die
Veränderungsbereitschaft in die
problemlose Lösungsfähigkeit von
Politikern das muss man auch sagen ist
seit 50 Jahren gibt es eine
Protestkultur in diesem Land die immer
also wirklich das ist ja schon
langweilig auf der Stelle treten sagt
sie wollen die anderen immer die anderen
aufrütteln es ist permanente
Aushandlungsprozess permanent gute und
Andreas Bade gemacht als sie die
Kaufhäuser angezündet haben ja ist auch
wenn sie das nicht wissen dann ist es
trotzdem so dass ihre Protest ihr
protest movement immer noch in diesem
ausreden lassen bitte
da sie die Kauf jetzt so nicht warum um
ein Zeichen zu setzen um aufzurütteln
damals ging es um Vietnam und es ging
übrigens auch schon damals um
konsumscheiße also es ist gar nicht so
wahnsinnig weit und dieses ich fand es
eigentlich eine Zumutung dass ich
dauernd aufgerüttelt werden soll von
solchen Aktionen und warum eigentlich
nicht innerhalb der Demokratie innerhalb
der Grünen innerhalb der Parteien warum
immer non govern Mantel warum immer
außer parlamentarisch warum nicht
innerhalb der Partei innerhalb der
Demokratie hypothetisch die Frage aber
ihre Mutter deren Gefährten würden sich
heute möglicherweise dieser Bewegung
anschließen oh das kann ich nicht
beurteilen aber die haben sich auf jeden
Fall eben mit diesen Fragen genau
rumgeschlagen also nicht mit dem Klima
aber die haben sich mit dem Fragen der
Proteste des aufmerksam machen dann
haben Sie erkannt dass die Gesellschaft
lässt sich nicht aufwecken und dann
haben sich einige radikalisiert und
gesagt wir müssen es mit roter
nein nein
nein
halbwegs logisch machen reden ähnlich
aber ganz ein anderes Thema sie haben
auch damals gedacht es nützt nichts weil
wir friedlich demonstrieren es nützt
dann im nächsten Gang nicht wenn wir
Sachbeschädigung machen und dann sind
einige das war ja nicht die ganze
Bewegung und das waren ja nur einige
haben dann gesagt wir müssen noch
Radikale werden ich glaube Herr Dr
Zander dass er nicht radikaler wird es
kann aber andere der Bewegung geben die
er gar nicht kennt und es kann Dynamik
sein aber ich will die auch gar nicht an
die Wand malen ich sage nur was ich viel
schlimmer finde ist dass es wir haben so
eine Art Liebe zu diesem Protestierenden
in diesem Land seit 68 Deutschland das
ist in Frankreich genauso das ist
überall so
eigentlich eigentlich alle Menschen sind
genauso
protestieren wir sind wir sind immer auf
der Seite wir auf der Gesellschaft die
Zeitung die Medien die Polizisten immer
auf der Seite sehr protestieren denn und
ich denke oft sie sollte doch vielleicht
mehr auf der Seite sein der die
versuchen in einer Demokratie ihre
Anliegen vorzulegen als immer denen die
es mit Gewalt und sabotageaken
entscheidend
durch mit dem Thema was erreicht und
Deutschland
1,8 Prozent der Welt Klimas ist in
in Russland ganz ganz anders vor der von
der amerikanischen finden Sie wie viel
auf welchem Platz Deutschland stehen
wenn man 1800 kommen auf 1850 bis heute
ganz normal
die Radikalisierung die ja auch zum Teil
in der Klima Protestbewegung jetzt schon
da ist jetzt nur Datenschutz was
innenminister Herrmann gesagt hat im
vorsorgen der Staat da muss die Regeln
neu justieren wenn wir sehen dass es
sich radik passiert dass sozusagen die
Schwere der Taten größer wird ein
heftiger wird dann gibt es gerade
Initiative die Macht die cdu/csu jetzt
diese Woche im Deutschen Bundestag dass
wir auch darüber reden müssen müssen wir
im Strafgesetzbuch neue Tatbestände
verankern die darauf Rücksicht nehmen
dass möglicherweise die Eingriffe durch
den Protest stärker werden dass die
Schwere der Taten größer wird und
deswegen da auch eine Freiheitsstrafe
eine mindestfreiheitsstrafe
implementiert wird im Strafgesetzbuch
der mit Richter bei Wiederholungstätern
bei intensivstraftätern dann auch eine
mindestfreiheitsstrafe verhängen können
und eben nicht nur vielleicht ein paar
hundert Euro Strafgeld und dann ist
alles wieder alleine
präventiv möglicherweise wirkt weil das
ist ja das was die Autofahrer auf den
Straßen für Tag immer wieder passiert
können Sie garantieren dass das in drei
in sechs Monaten vorbei ist
ich kann das nicht garantieren weil ich
nie garantieren kann was jemand nächste
Woche oder in einem halben Jahr für
Unfug macht aber was ich garantieren
kann ist dass wir konsequent gegen alle
Rechtsprecher vorgehen werden und ich
kann feststellen nach wie vor zu 99%
rollt der Verkehr in Bayern egal ob das
im Züge oder um Autos und wir werden
weiterhin alles dafür tun solchen Unfug
in Grenzen zu halten
das bescheidenes anmerken was bescheiden
ist von ihnen bescheiden ist nämlich
dass die ganze Diskussion hier langsam
das was er macht enorm hochjubelt auch
was die da alles erzählen was sie für
für Maßnahmen ergreifen wollen das ist
hier an dem was auf der Erde geschieht
das was im Mittelmeer geschieht das was
in der Ukraine was in Afrika geschieht
ihr nehmt euch zu wichtig ihr nehmt euch
so wichtig mit diesem kleinen
wir machen ein ganz kurzes Pause wie wir
uns irgendwann hier Wiedersehen
Innenminister danke nach München nächste
Woche wieder hier bei Bild die richtigen
Fragen Montagabend
[Musik]